.
I'M TRACY GALLAGHER ARE NOW BACK
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
>> THE FIRST PART OF HER
CONVERSATION WITH MIKE TYSON
LAST NIGHT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
INTERVIEWS AND THAT WAS
INTERESTING THERE WAS EVER DONE.
BUT I GOT EVEN BETTER,
MIKE TYSON AS IT TURNS OUT, AND
DOESN'T JUST LOVE ANIMALS BUT HE
WATCHES THEM VERY CAREFULLY
LEARNS A LOT AND HE TELLS US
WHAT IT'S LIKE DELIVERED TO
TIGERS ON HIS BED, AND HE TOLD
US HOW WE FELT ABOUT THE MEN HE
FACED OFF AGAINST IN THE RING.
HE'S A HAND, HE WANTED TO KILL
THEM AND HE REALLY MEANT IT.
HERE'S PART OF THE SECOND HALF
OF OUR CONVERSATION WITH
MIKE TYSON WITH TUCKER CARLSON
TODAY.
♪ ♪
>> HOW DID YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
GUYS YOU IN THE RING WITH?
>> I WANTED TO KILL THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker Carlson: WHAT I CAN
TELL.
WHY DID, I'M LAUGHING NERVOUSLY.
WHY DID, YOU REALLY FELT THAT
WITH?
>> WILL YES.
>> Tucker Carlson: HOW DID YOU
GET YOURSELF INTO A FRAME OF
MIND THEY WANT TO KILL THEM?
>> YOU THINK ABOUT WHO I AM
AND I DON'T WANT TO GO BACK
THERE, I DON'T WANT TO BE IN
THAT POVERTY STATE OF MIND
ANYMORE.
NOT FROM A PHYSICAL, I DON'T
WANT TO BE POVERTY-STRICKEN
HERE.
>> Tucker Carlson: OUT SO YOU
WOULD SIT AND THINK ABOUT IT THE
GUY YOU ARE ABOUT TO FIGHT?
>> YES ABSOLUTELY, THE
MILLIONAIRES AND THE HIGHER YOU
GO LIKE.
THAT'S JUST MY MENTALITY.
THE MORE YOU HURT THEM, AND THE
PEOPLE LOVE YOU.
>> Tucker Carlson: WOW THAT'S
PRETTY INTENSE AND TRUE I GUESS.
SO, WHEN YOU KNOCK THEM OUT YOU
WERE SATISFIED?
KATHY?
>> KIND OF YET.
STAY WELL WHY DON'T YOU WANT TO
SAY?
>> IT WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH.
AT THAT TIME OF MY LIFE IT WAS
NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
>> YOU WANTED TO KEEP GOING?
>> YES I WANT TO CRUSH US.
IT RUINED EVERYTHING HE COULD
BE.
FEELS LIKE FIRE, IF YOU KNOW IT
OR CONTROLLER IT KEEPS US ALL
WARM IT KEEPS US FULL HEAT OUR
FOOD, BUT IT CAN DESTROY YOU AND
EVERYTHING AROUND YOU.
>> Tucker Carlson: THAT SUCH A
SMART POINT.
HOW DO YOU KEEP IT IN ITS BOX
WAS THE NUCLEAR REACTOR DIFFUSE
YOU BUT IS NOT THE FORCE FIRE?
TO BE 100 NODES A PROGRAM.
I CAN BE IN A ROOM WITH A BUNCH
OF REALLY BAD OR INTERESTING
PEOPLE, THAT I MAY BE SHOULD
INDEED BE TO LEAVE THAT ROOM.
BUT IT'S JUST LIKE PROJECTION OF
HOW I FEEL IN OUR PROJECTS ON
EVERYONE ELSE.
>> Tucker Carlson: HAVE YOU IN
THE YEAR SINCE THOSE FIGHTS HAVE
YOU STAYED IN TOUCH WITH ANY OF
THE GUYS THAT YOU FALL?
>> FOLEY FIELD.
>> FOLEY FIELD?
>> DENNIS RODMAN, >> AND THE
T'S SEEDS GO VIVID BUSINESS?
>> MARIJUANA, DEBATE, THE MIC
BITES.
THAT WAS MISSING BEING ABLE TO
COME OUT WITH THAT.
AND BEEN BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL AT
THAT AND I'M SO HAPPY THAT -- IS
WHAT I SAID.
WE'RE THE ONLY FIGHTER IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD THIS IS AN
APPEAL FROM A FIGHT 25 YEARS
AGO.
WHO'S DOING THAT?
>> DO YOU STILL HAVE TIGERS?
>> NO I SAW LITTLE KIDS.
>> SO WHEN YOUR KIDS GET OLDER
YOU HAVE TIGERS AGAIN?
>> I WOULD HAVE NOT BEEN
STRONG ENOUGH TO HANDLE THEM.
YOU GOT TO BE TOUGH WITH THEM
SOME TIME.
>> REALLY?
>> LISTEN, NOT THE TIGERS AS
MUCH BECAUSE THEY GET OFFENDED,
WHEN YOU REPRIMAND THEM, BUT THE
LINES ARE LIKE DOGS.
TAKE IT OVER HERE.
JUST LIKE DOGS.
SHE DOES TOO, SHE DOES BARK THEY
DON'T GO OUT LIKE CATS THEY BIKE
THEIR BARK THEY BITE.
MOST CATS ARE THERE IN THE DOG
FAMILY.
>> REALLY?
A CHEETAH BEHAVE LIKE ADELE?
>> A CHEETAH, AND A LION,
TOGGLED NOT SO MUCH BY JUST TELL
THEM TO DO HER ATTACKS AND A
JUMP ON YOU AND THE COME OUT
WITH YOU, TARGUS AND I LIKE
THAT.
THEY JUST WANT TO HANG OUT WITH
YOU THAT ONLY FRIENDS AND NO ONE
ELSE.
>> IS A DANGEROUS TO HAVE
FRIENDS OVER WHEN YOU HAVE
TIGERS?
>> I SHOULD HAVE AN OCCASION
THE FRIENDS COME OVER.
SO, YOU'RE SAYING THAT AS YOU
GET OLDER, AND YOU BECOME LESS
AGGRESSIVE THE CT SCAN'S MOTHER?
>> YES, THEY NEED TO BE PUT IN
THEIR PLACE, TIGER KNOWS ASP PUT
IN THIS PLACE IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO PUT THEM IN THIS PLACE
ARE THERE TO PUT THEM IN YOUR
PLACE.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE A CUSTOM
MODEL.
>> IS AN EMPTY POODLE, BUT
LISTEN, YOU CAN TEACH THESE
CATS, TEACH THEM, BUT VERY FEW,
ONLY A HALF A PERCENT CAN BE
TRAINED.
YOU CAN'T TAME THEM.
YOU CAN TRAIN THEM THEY CAN'T
TAME THEM.
>> WHAT IS A DIFFERENCE?
>> IF YOU TRAIN AND THEY DO
TRICKS.
THEY DO THIS AND THEY PUT THEM
BOY.
WE HAVE AND THEM THEY HAVE AN
EFFECT ON YOU.
>> YOU COULD DO >> YES.
BUT I HAD TIGERS IN MY BED, AND
A HALF THEM IN THE BED, AND
THEIR BED THEY WANT TO GET
CLOSE, THEY HAVE TO FORGE A PART
CATS BITING YOU.
A GENERAL TO THE FLOOR, ROLL ON
THE FLOOR AND THEY FIND ON THE
BED.
AND THEY WANT TO GET CLOSE TO.
>> HOW DO YOU BREAK UP A TIGER
IF I >> I DON'T.
THIS GUY COMES ON.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THREE IN THE MORNING IN
YOUR BEDROOM?
>> ME FIGHTING WITH THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I DON'T THINK I CAN HANDLE
THAT LEVEL OF TRAUMA.
>> I DON'T THINK I COULD
EITHER.
THIS IS NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE
EVEN WHEN THEIR FIRSTBORN.
NEVER HAPPEN, NEVER THOUGHT
ABOUT BRINGING THEM UP TO COME
UPSTAIRS, HANGING OUT THE LISTEN
IF THEY EVER FOUGHT, THE WHOLE
HOUSE YOU HAVE TO LEAVE.
BECAUSE THEY FOUGHT -- OH, GOD.
I HAVE TO GET THE WHOLE HOUSE,
FLUSHED OUT.
>> Tucker Carlson: WHY?
>> YOU THINK SOMEBODY THREW A
NUCLEAR BOMB, BECAUSE YOU CAN
BREATHE.
>> Tucker Carlson: ALL OF THE
MOSQUE?
>> YES.
>> AND SOMETIMES IF YOU ARE
NOT CAREFUL THEY WALKED BY AND
HIT YOU WITH THE SMELL.
DAVID P ON YOU SOMETIMES
>> OUT OF LOVE?
>> SOMETIMES THEY PICKED THEM
OFF, SOMETIMES THEY'D -- THEY
RUB INTO YOU.
AND IT COMES FROM THE BACK.
IT COMES OUT, AND IT -- AND THE
SMELL OF THE, HOLY SMOKES.
>> IS REALLY STRONG?
>> LISTEN PNEUMONIA HAS
NOTHING ON THAT.
>> YOU CAN PASS OUT.
AND WHEN THEY DO IT, IT COMES
OUT LIKE A STREAM.
IN THE TALE GOES UP AND THEY GO
BOW.
AND IT HITS YOU.
AND HE DIED FROM THE SMELL, THE
SMELL IS WORSE THAN --
>> Tucker Carlson: HOW LONG
DID YOU HAVE BIG CATS IN YOUR
HAWKS?
>> 1413 YEARS.
WHEN PEOPLE CAME IN DEAD PUT
THEM IN THE CAGE.
>> Tucker Carlson: DID YOU
EVER WAY YOU ARE GETTING A BIT
IN?
>> I SHOULD'VE BEEN.
BUT THEY SAID I'VE GOT THESE BIG
CATS ON THE CONTROL.
WHEN THEY TRY TO JUMP ON ME, IF
YOU HAVE THE IDEA FOR YOU TO
SHOW THEM RESPECT.
YOU DON'T SHOW RESPECT TO THESE
ANIMALS YOU FINISH.
YOU GOT TO KISS SOME LEVEL,
STROKE HIM.
I SHALL OF.
>> Tucker Carlson: THE WHOLE
SECOND HALF OF THE INTERVIEW